this green sea turtle is providing free
transportation to a few hitchhikers the
turtle was seen swimming with these
passengers off the coast of dahab egypt
[Music]
sea turtles often have organisms that
attach themselves to their shell some
are in fact parasitic while others are
commensal posing no threat to the turtle
crabs barnacles shrimp oysters algae and
other life-forms have all been seen on
the Turtles
the non parasitic organisms mainly used
the turtle as a form of transportation
green sea turtles have amazingly long
lifespans often reaching 80 or more
years
sadly green turtles are listed as an
endangered species they are killed for
their meat and eggs
loss of habitat boating accidents and
fishing nets also contribute to a
declining number of the species
[Music]
[Applause]